I'm just writing and directing interest
to more than acting did you ever have
ambition sad no I never had ambitions
act I mean I've acted in friends you
know little pieces here and there and
enjoy it but I never thought about
pursuing it on my own I've never seen Oh
thought oh I'd like to go audition for
these things you know it's a little bit
of a lark for me but not something that
I'm really drawn to what is it about
being a lark we've heard of actors say
sometimes it's like chasing fool's gold
thinking that you're going to go on
these auditions and you will be the one
to get it is it is it the pursuit of it
that seems difficult to you well I think
it's probably I think it's more just the
the state of putting yourself out there
so so naked every time and you know that
I'm not sure that I would want to deal
with and yeah I like the role of writing
and directing more you know so i guess i
don't know I've never had that as a
desire so it's tough to say well why why
it isn't I don't know do you think it's
less harsh or difficult to be a writer
and director and put yourself out there
and people there believe they love it or
hate it or they'll just be neutral about
it it does it feel less like you're
baring your soul even though I'm sure a
lot of what you you're right probably
has a lot of weimar you know what might
have there might be some of that I I
think a lot of it is just you know it
might be more about control you know
when you're writing and directing
something you're there from the blank
page to the final edit of the piece you
know when you're an actor you know what
you're giving to the movie is enormous
but you're there for a very short amount
of time and you know so there's just a
very big difference for what you're
carrying in terms of control and whether
project you know is going to see it an
end and actually be something when
you're the writer director vs I guess
acting in that way you know not to say
that that they're less than one another
but the role is very very different you
know I mean I I would still say even in
talking about you know working with
actors before at film school and
I you know I probably came in with
perception and it's only strengthened
over time that that you know good actors
i know it's underestimated in probably
you know people talk about how much
these actors are paid and everything and
that you know they get paid these
absorbent amounts and yeah i mean the
people who are good at this you know
it's a deserved thing I mean it's just
yeah its people really underestimate how
difficult it is and so you know that's
what I'm sure that's part of it for
myself as I see how hard it would be and
you know I don't think I'm as good at it
as these other people so why would I try
to do
you